[موسيقى]
هناك بعض التحديات التي تعاني منها المراه
المسيحيه فعلى سبيل المثال عدم تقبل فكره
الانصبه الارثيه المتساويه بين الذكور
والاناث وقد يكون السبب في ذلك
الموروث الاجتماعي السائد التخبط بين فكره
الموروث الاجتماعي السائد والانتماء
الديني هاد بيعمل نوع من الاشكاليه في
المجتمع المسيحي لكن قله من الناس هي التي
يعني تنظر للموضوع بهاي الطريقه في
الديانه المسيحيه ما في قوانين واضحه
وصريحه تتعلق بموضوع الارث لكن السبب
الرئيسي لتطبيق
الشريعه
الشريعه الاسلاميه
وقواعدها الفقهيه في عمليه تقسيم الارث في
المسيحيه هو ما جاء في الماده 1686 من
القانون المدني والتي تنص على انه يطبق
احكام الشريعه الاسلاميه على جميع
الاردنيين فيما يتعلق بالميراث فهي حكت
على جميع الاردنيين ما وضحت انه سواء كان
مسيحي او مسلم فمن هذا المنطلق انه بلشنا
نطبق احكام الشريعه الاسلاميه
في المسيحيه
[موسيقى]
الحكومه التعديل باجماع الكنائس على مسوده
قانون مشترك قبل عرضه على مجلس النواب
وذلك اعتمادا على المواد الموجوده في
الدستور قانون يجب ان يظهر في مراحل عده
احنا في البدايات كنا بنحاول ان ناتي
بقانون وكان هناك جهد كبير من الكثير من
الناس
المختصين من محامين من كهنه
من اعضاء في الكنيسه لي بلوره هذا القانون
وتم بلوره نسخه جيده جدا في هذا المجال
واليوم يجب ان يتوافق عليها مجلس الكنائس
ومن ثم ان تذهب في القنوات التشريعيه
الصحيحه حتى الان القانون لم يذهب في
القنوات التشريعيه الصحيحه ومازال
باعتقادي عن مجلس الكنائس ممكن والذي
بدوره عليه واجب اليوم ان يتجه بسرعه بهذا
الاتجاه
[موسيقى]
90% اذا مش 99% من المسيحيين في هذا
الكلام لكن واضح ان هناك البعض وقد تكون
لقضايا ماليه وقد تكون لقضايا تتعلق بانه
يعني لا يريد ان تخرج او ان يخرج
الميراث خارج حلقه معينه وبالتالي
يعارضوا هذا القانون لكن انا اعتقد انه
علينا ان نعمل بهذا الاتجاه وسن القانون
واضح بهذا الخصوص وهو قانون يخص
المسيحيين الاردني فقط ولا يخص كل
المواطنين الاردني
[موسيقى]